one of the big assumptions of our times
is that if love is real it must by
definition
prove to be eternal we invariably and
naturally equate
genuine relationships with lifelong
relationships and therefore
it seems almost impossible for us to
interpret the ending of a union
after only a limited period a few weeks
or
five or ten years or anything short of
our or the partner's
death date as something other than a
problem
a failure and an emotional catastrophe
that is
someone's fault probably our own
there are people desperate that they've
failed because their relationships have
lasted
only 32 years we appear
fundamentally unable to trust that a
relationship could be at once
sincere meaningful and important and yet
at the same time
fairly and guiltlessly limited in its
duration
there are of course a few very good
reasons for our collective valorization
of the lifelong love story a great many
of the pleasures and virtues of
relationships
do only reveal themselves over time once
trust has been established
and loyalty fully demonstrated when two
people know it's forever
they will work harder than at anything
else in their lives there's no option to
avoid some necessary but unpleasant
issues
they will do their utmost to understand
the mysteries of the other's psyche
they will show reserves of tenderness
and vulnerability
they wouldn't ever otherwise have
accessed they will learn to apologize
and reach a modesty about their own
shortcomings they will grow up
and in the meantime day to day they will
sample the modest but genuine pleasures
of
cozy sunday evenings together and shared
walks in country parks
not least children always benefit
but it's because the charms of the long
term are so clear in our collective
imaginations
that we should acknowledge the danger of
cruelly and normatively suppressing
all the legitimate claims of short-term
love
an arrangement which deserves to be
interpreted not merely as a
pathologically
stunted or interrupted version of a
long-term union
but as a state with distinctive virtues
of its own
one that we might rationally choose from
the outset
knowing from the start that it would be
better for both parties
if there was a termination point more or
less in view
so much can go right with short-term
love
when two people know they don't own each
other they're extremely careful to earn
each other's respect on a daily basis
knowing someone could leave us at any
time isn't only grounds for insecurity
it's a constant catalyst for tender
appreciation
when it isn't forever we can let
differences lie
if the journey is to be long absolute
alignment can feel key
but when the time is short we're ready
to surrender our entrenched positions
to be unthreatened by novelties and
dissonances
the distinctive things they have in
their fridge and the peculiar things
they like to watch and listen to
aren't affronts to our values they're
unthreatening invitations to expand our
personalities
very few of us come out well from being
closely observed 24 hours a day
in a limited space these may simply not
be the preconditions for getting the
best out of some of us
our interesting and generous sides may
need in order to emerge
our own bedroom and bathroom quite a few
hours to ourselves
some space to read and think and a
series of meal times alone
staring rather blankly out of the window
without having to explain
how we feel it's not a sign of evil just
what we require to be the best version
of ourselves
what makes people difficult and dooms
relationships is almost never
the people involved it's what we're
trying to do with them
inviting someone to marry you is really
not a very kind thing
to do to someone you love because it's
going to drag the beloved
into a range of really rather unpleasant
and challenging things
doing the accounts with you meeting your
family regularly
seeing you exhausted and bleary-eyed
after work
keeping the living room tidy bringing up
a child
to really love someone that is to wish
the best for someone
might more fairly mean foregrounding
your best qualities for a few ecstatic
months
and then mutually and tenderly parting
at the check-in desk long-term
relationships
rewards some qualities especially the
administrative ones
but they obscure others for example
those related to skills that having
interesting
speculative conversations about ethics
or the meaning of life
late into the night it should be no
insult to determine that some people
simply won't be able to shine in the
conditions of long-term love
and that it's very kindly playing up to
their strengths
to leave them long before we ever need
to try to arrange
a cutlery draw with them we should be
aware of succumbing to the debilitating
feeling
that because it didn't last forever it
can have been nothing at all
in other areas of life we know that
going on forever
isn't the ideal even when something is
very good
we don't necessarily think we have to
stay in the same house all our lives
though we might really like the one
we're in we're not betraying it or
destroying it when we recognize
that for a range of reasons it might be
wise us to move elsewhere
we need to have an account of love which
allows that a relationship can end
without anyone having viciously or
pathologically killed it prematurely
for only against such a backdrop can we
reduce the debilitating quantity of
bitterness
guilt and blame that's otherwise in
circulation
how we see the endings of love depends
to a critical extent
on what our societies tell us is normal
if it was meant to last forever then
every ending
will by necessity have to be described
as a horrifying failure but if we allow
imaginative space
for short-term love then an ending may
signal a deeper loyalty
not to setting up a home and domestic
routines
but to a deep appreciation and
admiration one felt for someone
for a time we'll walk away with a fair
and generous sense
of all that's been preserved and
enhanced by the relationship
not being forced to last forever
you